Sasha hi hi I'm here okay so in the
private chat you said that you that you
have a girlfriend she wants to wait
until marriage for sex but you did have
intercourse with her
uh yes sir so um we're both 19
um we started dating four months ago and
uh when we started dating uh I found out
that she is a virgin
and going forward I understood that it's
not a lie
and uh she just said to me in the
beginning that she's not necessarily
waiting for marriage she's just waiting
for a right moment
um and we had that right moment I find
like Jiu Jitsu competition just happened
you know
at your Jujitsu competition yeah yeah
we're out of town you know like did you
just win
I I got second place for the first time
in Black Belt uh division so I'm very
happy
competitors were in that
um in the black belt bracket it was five
so relatively small division but um
yeah yeah I got second place not bad not
bad yeah you know what like I said like
this is one of the things that really
turns women on is when they see a man
chasing Excellence doing something
competitive and winning
um you didn't come in first but even
second place was good enough for at that
occasion to
hey let's get it on right 100 100
um so yeah and when it happened
um obviously it was consensual but after
um I don't know if this is her
upbringing
um she does have a single mom
and uh she just started regretting it
and she said that it was like almost a
traumatic experience after the like the
regret itself
um and I was like hey you know what
listen it's fine we'll just do it
whenever it happens again like let it
happen organically
and uh weeks past and it's just been in
game it's been getting worse and worse
and she gave me an ultimatum almost as
if like hey like I can't go against my
heart reality is like I want to wait
till marriage
um and yeah I'm I was kind of
I don't know I'm not I wasn't sure what
to do you know well this is a difficult
situation for a man because
if you have a man that has a bus pass
and he's been taking the bus for years
and then you throw in the keys to a
sports car
BMW maybe something nicer like a McLaren
and then he drives that and then you
take away the keys and say sorry now
that you've had to go you can't have
this ever again you're gonna have to
take the bus again until I say so
that's that's a very difficult
predicament for men to be and you know I
had this um I had this gal
um who purportedly was a 21 year old
virgin and
um You probably you know some of you
guys watching right now will know that I
had this uh scheduled for a plane to win
podcast because I legitimately wanted to
dive into the topic with her and um
you know see what kind of assistance I
could offer because she's basically like
every guy that I'm with uh you know they
want to bang me and then they dump me or
they'll cheat on me and it's like
you know I mean I never did the show uh
long story short so it's not there
because she wouldn't verify her identity
um you know she gave me social media and
I looked at that but she wouldn't turn
on her camera you know before the show
so I didn't believe that she was who she
said she was but long story short I mean
you get situations like this where women
will deny you sex unless you marry them
fine uh perhaps a noble thing to do
but then they get mad if you've already
had sex either with her or you know in
most cases with somebody else and they
want you to deny having sex until they
say so and then they get mad if you
cheat on them right it's like you know
this whole thing like you know if you've
been driving a McLaren and then you're
told to throw away the keys and get on
the bus you're gonna be like
for really like for how long like I have
to do that sort of thing so it's a
difficult per you know predicament if
you don't have
and by the way it's different for men
and women too like Notch counts do not
affect men the way that they affect
women women have a a very low likelihood
of being happy in a long-term marriage
let me get these uh the graph here
because I haven't saved in my phone
um
so if you're a
a virgin at marriage your chance your
chances of Happiness calculated over a
10-year span of time and this is
um from the teachman study uh sorry
there's two studies a teachman study and
the Heritage study
um you have an 80 chance of being happy
in that marriage after 10 years if
you're married as a virgin as a woman
if you've had one partner that drops to
53 percent if you've had five Partners
it drops to 29 percent
so if if marriage is important to you if
you have religious convictions then you
should marry a virgin you know I mean
the data seems very very clear on that
um the chances of you finding a virgin
is very very remote in North America and
the older the woman is the more remote
the chances you find in one are going to
be so while it's a noble cause like does
it matter to you you know do you see her
as wife material is she going to be the
mother of your kids is this a religious
issue for you like if all those things
are no no no no no no and you just want
to have some sex and you know chasing
Excellence is more important then I
would let her go
well I would say certainly uh this girl
has genuine burning desire I have read
your book and she does not have a lot of
like like red flags
um I would say the only one is jealousy
it does have maybe it does have to do
with the fact I've had Partners before
and she didn't you know
but
um I'm just four months into this
relation relationship four months is not
a lot of time you don't know what this
chick's made of
right so you don't know how she's going
to react to stress you don't know any of
these things until they start happening
over time right so
the again you know the question that
that you're asking is I like sex I'd
like to have sex we had sex now she
doesn't want to have sex she's you know
reneging on it
um she's got more than one red flag I
mean you said that she's got jealousy
issues but she's also from a single
mother household and she doesn't have a
relationship with her father right yeah
that is so you'll probably start to see
more and more as you know time goes on
you know they start to pop up like
a chick from a stable household is a
better choice than a chick from a single
mother household every every single time
right so again you're only four months
into this thing here right so I would
look dude you're a young man and you
don't know a lot about women and it's
the whole thing like you don't know what
you don't know so if if you're not
religious it doesn't sound like you are
not really no not really as much you
know so why would you abandon your
sexual strategy why would you abandon
what matters to you because somebody
else tells you to do so and they may not
be you know
a great choice four months in right so
like think about it like all all I'm
saying is think about what matters to
you I'm not saying do it I'm not saying
don't do it I'm saying put yourself
first and think about what matters to
you right I want to ask you a question
about this
um if I were to wait would that be
considered I don't know if it's the
right word will that be considered weak
as if I'm going into her manipulation so
yeah I don't know it is it is because
because she's already had sex with you
she's already consensually wanted you
she's had genuine burden desire she's
already had sex with you when you won
the competition you know when you came
in second place she's already done it
right right so it's like again it's like
you know here's the keys to my McLaren
go drive it then you take the keys away
and say [__] you you can't have it
anymore
not until you put a ring on this finger
yeah right I see what you mean yeah I
was just like that's a game like that's
a game like I would have more respect
for her if she was a virgin maintained
her virginity and didn't give it up and
then and then say oh now that I've given
it up and giving you a little taste of
the cookie you can never have the cookie
again
mm-hmm all right I completely understand
that see what I'm saying of course 100 I
said you know it's one of those things
man like you're going to have to think
about this one you know for yourself
for sure yeah I'm taking some time for
that yeah you were the guy that DM me
right
I was yes I did yeah very good see this
man paid attention to the you know to
the autoresponder call in on the show
ask these questions you guys help me out
by allowing me to create content on
these interesting topics and you get
answers too right of course 100 100 all
right and and lastly I wanted to ask
this is out of topic
um I am a Jitsu competitor and I am
young 19. yeah um I'm not in college
currently and uh I have this pressure
that um I should be in college but I am
chasing Excellence I'm in a big gym for
jiu jitsu
um and I have big goals in competing
like I mean I mean I've been doing this
for years and
um that's the only my that's the only
concern is financial Excellence um I
mean I I did get my real estate license
working with my dad um under his
brokerage and I was just I was just
curious because I I'm feeling a pressure
like as if I can't do these two things
at the same time time and Achieve
success as if I have to focus on one and
this pressure is coming kind of from my
father well you can you can train in
Combat Sports and do real estate
but do you believe you could be a
professional in Combat Sports and do
real estate at the same time uh
okay well I mean the problem with
selling real estate is you're on call
pretty much all the time if you have a
class scheduler or a competition on a
weekend and you get a call from a client
to you know take a look at a house that
might net you 30 Grand in commission
you've got a difficult decision to make
right 100 so it so so it could
potentially conflict there are things
that you can do to earn an income that
wouldn't conflict that's one of the
downsides to real estate
I remember was out on a date once with
this gal that was a real estate agent
like I just don't [__] like I
wouldn't date them again or let them
pull this [__] but this is you know long
before I unplugged all this sort of
stuff and we're sitting there having
sushi and she gets a text message she's
like I gotta go I'm like go where
exactly all I got to do a showing you
know I got a client that needs to see
this house right now and it looks like
it's going to sell I'm like you got to
be [__] kidding like you know this is
the life of a real estate agent I see
right I see um one of the good things by
the way if if you're good at Jiu Jitsu
and you're competing is
you know you call it a good thing or a
bad thing but you're probably going to
find that women will start throwing
themselves at you or expressing
significant interests especially when
you're winning I I certainly found that
it's crazy because I mean growing up as
a teenager I had no attention from girls
at all I was super unconfident and uh as
soon as I went through puberty and I
just started being active on Instagram
it's just been non-stop like it's been
Non-Stop and that's why she has jealousy
because she has competition anxiety
around it because she knows that you
could get it and she gave it to you when
you you know were at a competition it
came in second place so she's always
going to have that anxiety around it
right most definitely if she brings she
actually brings it up um like oh well
you don't understand my side because you
already have this much bodies before me
so
it's I don't know kind of a manipulation
tactic I guess don't let women
manipulate you man 100 100
thank you for the book Thank you all
right see you buddy all right thanks I
really hope you guys enjoyed that clip
if you want to watch the full length
podcast you can find that over here that
clips from if you're new to the channel
make sure you hit subscribe over here
and pin down below in the top comment
you'll find a bunch of useful links to
my website my supplement line books and
a bunch of other stuff have an amazing
day peace out